and are you thinking - I'm thinking it
we're all thinking it oh no everyone who
hasn't written Shyamalan off by now
we're all like come on man come on
here's open lit so splint is the new
movie by M night Shyamalan nothing you
don't know there was a time it was going
to be the next bill bargain something
happened anyhow this is the newest movie
by M night Shyamalan in which it started
James McAvoy as someone who has 23
personalities in this added multiple
personality disorder kidnaps these girls
who then have to deal with the fact that
this dude has multiple personality
disorders and he's generally speaking to
creepy guys just a bit we have ourselves
an M night Shyamalan thriller is moving
first of all to certain James McAvoy
right out the gate I'm going to say this
this dude is a phenomenal actor and he
was great in this movie for any parts as
movie falters McAvoy is there to pick it
back up
movie starts dipping in parts where he's
not but when McAvoy is on-screen man
this is his film and he is carrying it
there are scenes where he's having
conversations with himself in his head
in the same shot gonna harken back to
when Willem Dafoe did it and spider-man
the first Raimi spider-man where he's
talking to himself in the mirror his
performance you really feel like these
are separate people inside this one
person is harder to do than people think
so all the credit to McEvoy and
Shyamalan has a director also the main
girl in here this girl is phenomenal she
was in the woods of Maine girl in the
witch whose career has climbed since
then and we're going to see ran a lot
more stuff basically the main actors in
this movie are great there are some
supporting actors who are not I like
those people who are not great in parts
are always not great but in true
Shyamalan fashions like the main stars
are good in the supporting characters
are like well you have unless is the
happening just everyone was bad in that
really what this movie as authors then a
very well acted film for James McAvoy in
the main girl and a creepy intense film
it really is Shyamalan returning to form
it's like the dude listen to us all
we're like dude you were somebody back
in the early 2000s you were going places
we love that Shyamalan where's he bring
him back granted he was going there with
the visit which I did enjoy for that
reason but I feel like when you make two
back-to-back it's like okay you'd be
like you were just messing around you
weren't dipping your toe in the water
you're telling is okay
well I get what you want I'll do that
now no more big-budget [ __ ] I think
that's fantastic not everything worked
in this movie there was these flashbacks
for the main girls past and I was like
why are they in here
I got wider in here I get what point
they ended up serving but it just wasn't
organically mixed almost like the entire
movie was shot in Shyamalan was like I
really need flashbacks to her childhood
so I'm going to film those I'm going to
try to find places to interject them
just didn't really mix and just sticks
out like a sore thumb also the movies a
slow burn the ball I'm praising this for
being true old-school Shyamalan fashion
it's his old school movies were like
that they were slow burn
guys in the end split is interesting
it's not for everybody that is for sure
it's Shyamalan returning to form for
like okay you like my old school ish
movie this is more in line with that not
that Airbender [ __ ] McAvoy is Fanta it's
one of those movies worth like did this
come out in December it was that like a
limited release in December and now is
white in January so McAvoy could be up
for Best Actor or supporting actor
whatever he would be the main girl was
great some of the supporting characters
and some of the pacing is a little wonky
it's a slow movie but in the end I
walked out really enjoying myself I will
say split is definitely a good time no
alcohol required right guys to split
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]